just hours after the Nevada legislative
session opened today the Clark County
Education Association laid out what they
want to see in our classrooms during a
rally this evening that you can see and
a good evening to you at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez Madison
Kimbrough was there and spoke to several
CCSD employees who say changes are
critical she joins us live tonight
outside of school headquarters
the message was clear from the ccea and
other Educators at today's rally as all
they want is kids here in the district
to succeed and they say it's vital for
lawmakers to hear from the front line
get rid of this administrative burden
that our people have to deal with so
real time is taught teaching these
students the Clark County Education
Association executive director John
velardita addressing the crowd Monday in
a rally for change we want to figure out
how we can get more additional time in
the schools particularly the elementary
school levels to have literacy centers
After School Mentor programs reading
centers because the proficiency levels
in reading and math are too well
legislators announced last week a 250
million dollar proposal for increasing
teacher salaries which is a step in the
right direction today or Monday
excellent but money is also needed to
retain and recruit Educators to build a
pipeline superintendent Dr Jara applaud
State leaders for focusing on raising
Nevada's investment in education but
District employees and parents like root
lauriano believe it's all about making
sure kids are prepared for adulthood and
have the tools to succeed we are putting
kids out there that are not quite ready
to be successful in our own communities
and I don't want my daughter to go
through that I want everybody to be held
to a high standard everybody should be
receiving a good education and everybody
should have a shot at being successful
receive a good education and be safe at
the same time teachers sharing other
challenges they face in the classroom
personally I've gotten hurt at school
from one of my students in the previous
school year to the point where I had to
have my arm in a sling I know a lot of
people will kind of dismiss it their
five you know how bad could it be what
we have some situations where we have
some at-risk students that need more
supports that aren't getting them
today's rally was held at the Grant
Sawyer building near downtown where the
legislative Council Bureau is located
reporting live here at CCSD headquarters
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now